well I'm organizing this huge harvest
festival and I need at least 80 local
businesses to participate and normally
this is the kind of thing I would love
to do but I'm just feeling really tired
I think maybe my allergies are acting up
I've already vomited like five times
today hmm so we've developed a
revenue-sharing a formula that will
hopefully appeal to most business owners
basically go home you're sick I'm not
sick it's just allergies come on guys
let me in there
you look tired and you're all sweating
all the time what's your Excuse you want
to go there Jerry no I'm sorry of you
leaving I thought we had a meeting no we
do it's just I think it's a little
chilly in here
are you okay your eyes are glassy oh my
god oh my she is she's sick are you sick
no yeah
she's sick that's why I'm wearing this
and misting myself with hand sanitizer I
am not sick I just have allergies okay
I took a claritin and I threw that up so
I took another one I threw that up and
then I took a third and it stayed down
I'm getting better all right you're
burning up you're burning up what I have
to get out of here
I have 2.8 percent body fat my body's
like a microchip a grain of sand could
destroy it
my body's a microchip Leslie go home no
I can't I can't go home has to get ready
for the Chamber of Secrets
if this meeting does not go perfectly
then the harvest festival is gonna be
over before it began I cannot go home
okay then who is your doctor Ann's my
doctor and she's the most beautiful
nurse in the world
come on no it's really hot okay well
that's your fever let's say I typed your
symptoms into the thing up here and it
says you could have network connectivity
problems 104 point one Leslie you're
dehydrated I'm admitting you if I was
sick could I do this
what are you doing cartwheels and we're
not doing them no hi Leslie good to see
you
wow you're really burning up can I get
some money for the cab that I took over
here please sure how much I'm not sure I
looked at the meter and it had Egyptian
hieroglyphics on it do you know the
exchange rate so should we do this oh
boy hold on be careful what the floor
and the wall just switched okay walk
very carefully
you know I find it a little insulting
that you don't trust me to handle this I
don't trust you okay it's this Harvest
Festival is my project it's my career on
the line and I just need to make sure
that I've done everything I can to make
it work okay it's show time
good evening everyone I'm Leslie monster
and this is Nightline every one of you
just by showing up here tonight has
already made history in days past the
harvest festival was the cornerstone of
pawnees small-business community a
week-long showcase for everything from
textiles to small farms by our estimates
as many as 30,000 people might attend
the festival and the monetary value of
that kind of direct customer to business
exposure is frankly incalculable the
time is now the place is Pawnee let's
make history
that was amazing that was a flu ridden
Michael Jordan at the 97 NBA Finals that
was Kirk Gibson hobbling up to the plate
and hitting a homer off of Dennis
Eckersley that was that was Leslie Knope
any question yes sir are we going to get
the same sales tax incentives we used to
that's a very good question sir and I
would counter with my own question which
is why is half of your face all swirly
okay unfortunately Leslie has another
very important meeting right now so if
you have any other questions you can
just direct them towards me give it up
everybody for Scott Bakula from quantum
leap all right okay excuse me I think I
should drive you to the hospital
good I'm wearing a tiara when I came in
here because if you happen upon it well
you have lady penny face retrieve it and
send it post hence
you